[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am your
host Jade warshaw your other host for
the day is Dr John
to my right give us a call the number is
8825 5225 we will talk about the things
that are concerning to you about your
life and your money uh I'm here as kind
of the money expert and my guy John is
here as your mental health and wellness
I don't know why I'm here we're thinking
about it we're figuring it out fig as we
go but give us a call like I said the
number is 8825 5225 we'll chop it up
with you let's go directly to the phone
lines uh we got Laura in Phoenix Arizona
what's going on
Laura Laura are you there did I get
her are you there okay it was my nails I
blame my nails are you there hello okay
what's going on Laura Jade's Nails got
in the way again again what's up Laura
yeah so I need help on So currently
we're on
30,000 in debt so we always sit down and
talk about about our debts um say like
we sit down on on a Monday everything
goes good and then the weekend starts um
we have an issue where my husband likes
to drink um like
Friday sometimes Friday through Sunday
wow and then during that time he like he
forgets about our like a budget well I
would think
so yeah so then that goes out the window
and then Monday comes and it's
like he's ready to start again yeah and
he's like what happened um we I thought
we had sat down and talked about our
budget how long's that's been going
on um I would say like six months we
we've tried
to get together and try to like pay off
our debt but it's just not working yeah
you're married to somebody who's really
struggling with
alcohol this has this is not a budgeting
issue at
all yeah this is a you love um someone
who's an
alcoholic yeah and it sucks because he
doesn't see it that way so it seems like
I'm the nagging wife right and here's uh
what you've got to
do um unfortunately there is no healing
in your marriage there's no healing in
your financial life there's no healing
in underneath underneath your marriage
and underneath your financial all that
all that leads to this moment where you
don't feel safe in your own house do
you no no none of that changes until he
chooses to get
clean and so no matter what the issue is
when somebody comes in and says hey I'm
struggling with X and Y and Z and I'm
drinking and I can't quit doing XY
substance nothing happens on the mental
health side the marriage side the
emotional until somebody says I'm going
to I'm willing to go get
clean and what that means is you have to
take care of
you because you're not safe and I I
don't even doubt that this guy loves you
but this guy's got some significant
struggles that he at this time is
unwilling to deal with and so you have
to make your safety priority number
one what does that mean it probably
means you need to find somewhere for him
or for you to go for 30 days and say hey
I'm not going to live with somebody
who's unsafe anymore I'm tired of being
on eggshells in my own house I'm tired
of not knowing where all our money goes
I'm tired of not knowing where you go
and then you come home on Monday and
kind of make it my fault like I thought
we had all this he's got to decide to do
something different and that means going
to a meeting starting tomorrow morning
even though tomorrow's Thanksgiving see
what I'm saying like this is this is a
way bigger deal than
budgets yeah and can I just be honest
with
you yeah you know this right
yeah I mean he doesn't get upset about
it he just says like like what's going
on like we sit down and then I'm like
well this is what happens and then he's
like oh you know what yeah you're right
I'm going to work on it so listen
behavior is a
language and what he's telling you is I
don't care what you and I agreed on I
don't care what you and I um I don't
care about our our marriage
Fidelity I don't care about our
agreements I don't care about our
Financial Health I care about going on
Friday and Saturday nights and doing
whatever the crap I want to do
period I don't care how you feel in my
own house I don't care if you feel like
I'm a liar I don't care if you can't
trust me I get to go party on Friday
Saturday and
Sunday yeah well he doesn't go party but
he drinks at home but okay well he's
he's going to disappear on his own house
on Friday Saturday Sunday yeah yeah
behavior is a language M and he's
talking to you loud and
clear so this this is the point when you
go get a friend you go get a pastor you
go get a therapist and you sit down and
come up with some really ironcloud
boundaries that are going to be brutal
for you to
enact it's going to break your
heart yeah and that might be there is no
alcohol in my home anymore
period if you if you lie to me and
commit Financial infidelity again then
I'm out I'm going to go move in with my
sister
you have to go to AA like your
boundaries have to be pretty tough at
this point is that
fair
yeah I can hear it on you you're worth
more than than what what the the life
you're living right
now
yeah Jade am I crazy no you're not crazy
I I hate this for you it's tough and you
know people all the time they call in
and they're talking about issues that
aren't they're not money issues and here
we're always telling people like combine
your money combine your money but there
are times where it's like there are
situations there like no don't combine
your money like you said you seek
counsel and I tell people all the the
time like there's This Acronym I use
about keeping your money safe and it's
like if you're in these situations like
you know our friend calling in here
Laura where you're concerned the first
thing is you need to seek counsel like
that's the S you got to seek counsel and
the a is if there's abuse and if there's
addiction that's when you got to do it
or the F Financial infidelity that
that's what we're looking at and then
they're going to give you the E which is
you can evaluate your options based on
the boundaries you have because I'd like
to say it's as easy as all right move
out tomorrow but it's not it's it's
never that easy and there's
always awake you know what I'm saying
always and so I would just encourage
anybody who's in that situation like I
said abuse addiction Financial
infidelity yeah you're not like you said
you're not safe in your own home and
that person can cannot have continued
access to the things that make you safe
right in your family that keeps your
kids safe cuz if you have somebody who's
spending all the money on substance and
your kid can't have groceries and your
kid can't eat and you can't get to work
because there's no money for gas yeah
you got to put some boundaries in place
and you have to say like you said that
in my home there will be none of this
and until this happens you will not have
access and that's probably the toughest
line that you can lay down but that's
loving yourself well and honestly that's
loving them well right and it's loving
this thing that we decided to create
together which is called a marriage
that's right that's right H it's so
tough I hate that she's going through
that I hate that it's happening you know
during a time like this the holidays
where you're supposed to be able to come
together with the ones you love
sometimes you have to create that
distance that separation and create that
boundary so that ultimately things can
get better and you can find Healing this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees every
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
more
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on you're listening to
the Ramsay show by the way thank you for
listening to the Ramsay show I'm your
host today Jade warshaw I am joined by
my buddy best-selling author host of the
Dr John deloney show the guy's name is
Dr John deloney if you were not sure
about that we are going to take your
calls all afternoon give us a call the
number Isle
5225 and we will help out sort you sit
sort out your situation uh let's go
straight to the phone lines we've got
Anthony and Anchorage Alaska what's
going on
Anthony hey how you guys doing today
doing good how can we help I'm calling
I've been struggling with um making my
payments every month to try and get out
of debt I've never missed a payment uh
since I've had started building my
credit but I can't afford um to make
more than the minimum payments and I'm
never able to catch up well and that's
the problem I'm facing how many payments
are you trying to make like how much
debt do you
have uh between my me and my wife both
we've got about 30,000 in Consumer Debt
and another 5,000 in student loans okay
so can you sort out for me what the
30,000
is uh it's all credit card vet
bills uh Furniture credit cards just bad
decision various credit card credit
lines correct okay and
um can you tell me what you guys are
earning each month
combined what you're taking home um
monthly take home after taxes uh I get
about 5,000 from my job after paying for
benefits and everything okay um
currently I'm a full-time student so I
get another $2,200 a month um for my
veteran benefits okay cool what about
your
wife uh my wife just started her own
business back in July right now she's
only making enough income to sustain her
business to pay her rent pay for her
supplies and stuff like that so her
towards any correct okay is there a
trajectory on that business like like
after half a year is there like an
honesty Reckoning like is just a really
nice hobby or we headed
somewhere we we've had that conversation
a little bit um we paid for her to go to
school and then she just started the
business in July ideally she needs to be
able to help contribute once I am no
longer a full-time student is the plan
right now what's the nature of the
business that she's
doing uh she is a aesthetician okay my
question is is there a way that she can
do that business and also bring in some
part-time income as
well and that's a discussion we just had
last week in regards to her looking into
some part-time work to at least be able
to help me pay some of this stuff down
cuz I don't have the time to pick up any
extra shifts between working full-time
and going to school fulltime I bring any
extra income and what does she feel
about
that uh she is open to it uh
unfortunately she doesn't nothing
against my wife she doesn't have any uh
college or post School secondary
training
so at is I don't think she needs it to
pick up parttime work and when I say
part-time like go make 20 bucks an hour
like I don't care I just want her
bringing in some form of income and I
think that's going to help in many ways
a it's going to help you guys get more
income in but two it's going to help
take a little bit of the heat off of her
in this thing that she's trying to build
right now she can still feel like all
right I'm building this thing for myself
but I'm also contributing in another way
that my family really needs right now
and that's going to help everybody so
that's kind of something put it on the
Shelf you and her think about it pray
about it what whatever but the reason
you called in is you've got this debt
here
$335,000 um of debt and you're feeling
the crunch of that because I mean it's
it's a lot it's a lot of payments that
you're you're throwing away you
mentioned it's $30,000 of various credit
lines so each month you're having to
keep track of that and I can tell you
firsthand when you've got all those
debtors that you've got to pay it's just
frustr it's just a lot to keep track of
and I think you're feeling that um the
price is the same that I would give
anybody regardless of the amount of debt
regardless of how many debts what I
would tell you to do is list these debts
from smallest to largest so those 30,000
I'd go through each one and be like all
right what is the smallest balance and
list them from smallest to largest via
balance all right and then it's like
okay now we know what it is we got to
pay these off and the method to pay that
off is simple you got to get cash on it
do you have any cash saved anywhere
that's not retirement money
I don't um all the all the cash I've had
in savings has kind of dwindled over the
last year between um my wife going back
to school and me kind of supplementing
everything um I've been doing the
snowball method a little bit I had about
40,000 in
debt earlier this summer and I paid off
some small $1,500 $2,000 bills whether
it's to the vet or for furniture or
whatnot so I've kind of taken care of
all the small stuff it's now coming
towards the bigger credit cards go ahead
I was going to say is this the time it
sounds like you got two people in school
you got a wife launching a business and
you're working fulltime is either one of
two things might just have to be true
this season that you're going to finish
school and you're going to
pause the your goal is going to be to
get out of school Dead free and then
you'reall going to attack this when you
get your full-time gig or I just need to
take six months off from school I need
to take a leave I had students do that
every single semester I took a number of
leaves across all my degrees MH for
various things that happened I had a kid
wife got sick had to go do this wanted
to make some more money whatever the
thing was and just saying I I'm going to
go earn 10,000 extra bucks in this
semester and get this stuff paid off or
15,000 bucks or whatever I'm like I've
got to do or your wife takes fulltime
work and says I'm just doing the an
esthetician stuff on the side as a hobby
until but y'all are all trying they're
all trying to do everything all the
dreams and dude you're I don't want to I
don't want to kick you while you're down
but 30,000 bucks is a ton of debt that's
like you and your wife really making
some hard calls for a very short perod
18 months Max see what I'm saying like
right so tell tell me what your world
look like if you quit school for a
semester you paused
school well the reason why part of the
reason why I went back to school is
because I get that monthly taxfree sttip
in yeah but is that just going to
school no and it goes directly into my
bank account I'm a veteran okay so I get
a GI Bill housing benefit okay it pays
me $2,200 a month taxfree in income
directly into my bank account what's
happened to that other $5,000
then uh I have a very large mortgage um
I ow
$47,000 on a mortgage I've only been in
the house for a year and a half what's
the monthly payment um $3,200 dang it
okay now there's the problem right there
lead with that next time well John you
detected that that okay there's your
problem right there sell your house
homie you can't you're so far above the
percentage I feel like I'm I'm stuck as
I sell my house uh I'm I'm going to lose
moneyy and go into a rental that's going
to cost me so well let's let's let's not
just be scared of that let's see if
that's actually true so what' you buy
the house for and what do you owe on it
and what would it sell for let's let's
actually ask those real questions and
see if that's
true we we were renting I was paying
$2,500 a month in rent this was the
beginning of 2022 okay looked into
purchasing our home we found a home
purchased it in May of 202 to uhhuh uh
45% interest it was roughly all the fees
ended up being close to 500,000 okay so
what do you owe on it uh 472,000 and
what can you sell it
for uh I don't have a locked in estimate
um according to my mortgage broker I
need somebody to come out and reevaluate
the home to get up to date if I'm you
I'm starting to get those numbers and I
am holding on as tight as I can for the
next few months because I want Own It 2
years so that you don't if you do have a
wifall on this that you're not hit with
capital gains and I want you to
seriously consider like if I was your
mama I'd be like you better do it sell
this house because it's half of it's
half it's so much and you're not there's
not a tra trajectory that you have shown
us that gets you there in the next even
5 years your wife's building a business
you're in school the business is not
making money yet and you're in debt and
I just think that when you get out from
under this house you are going to take a
giant deep breath do you have you don't
have any kids yet right uh I have a
six-year-old okay you have a
six-year-old so we're finding something
any honestly any at this point anything
that's less expensive then the over
$3,000 that you're spending right now is
going to help you and you're a veteran
brother so think of it through those
eyes through the that lens when you're
faced with a whole bunch of variables
and they don't all add up let's begin to
pull variables off the table things that
we thought were absolutes they're not
your wife doesn't have to start a new
business right now you don't have to be
in school you don't have to be in a big
$500,000 house all these things can come
off the table let's seek Freedom let's
don't seek to try to make duct tape this
chaos together let's seek Freedom over
all else right
[Music]
now
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion dollar in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey show thank you for
listening my name is Jade warshaw joined
by Dr John delone we're taking your
calls this hour the number Isle
5225 but quick shout out to you guys to
the folks listening uh to the show
whether you listen on podcast or maybe
you log into YouTubes and you watch it
on YouTube um or maybe you go directly
into the Ramsey app and you listen to it
through there number one we're just
grateful to have you because the fact of
the matter is without you guys there's
no show and nothing around here actually
happens cuz we need people like you to
watch it and enjoy it and for it to help
you and you've proven that it does
because you know this thing is like
number one in so many categories or if
not number one it's like right up there
so thank you for doing that as a matter
of fact we would like you to consider
continuing to do all that so keep
listening and while you're listening go
ahead and get on there and like And
subscribe and share it do all those
things because of this show has helped
you chances are it can help somebody
else and you might be the Catalyst to
make that happen so like subscribe share
we would be truly truly thankful in this
season of thankfulness so thank you so
much let's go to the phone lines we've
got Jackson in Grand Rapids Michigan
what's going on Jackson sorry Miss
Jackson what's up hi guys thank you so
much for taking my call so I'm going to
try and articulate my question the best
I can okay um so I'm fairly new to
listening to you guys over the last
couple weeks and I've um introduced this
whole plan to my wife and we've got
oursel in quite the whole and my main
question is she deals with a lot of um
mental illness and she has U really hard
time like seeing the big picture and
honestly it's all very overwhelming for
me as well but I'm kind of like the
backbone to everything and um just
trying to get her fully on on board with
everything
and not thinking that this isn't
something that we're capable of
doing well what when you say she what's
she struggling with
specifically um she has depression
anxiety um she's been diagnosed with
borderline um personality disorder um
add so it's just kind of like a handful
so the first thing if if somebody if if
I meet somebody and they come to me and
say I've been diagnosed with all of
these things the first thing I'm going
to tell them whether it's my friend or
that somebody's in a coaching situation
with me or a family member I would tell
them I need you to go find a new
provider and get
re-evaluated because that's a lot of
that's a lot of variation there that's
all over it's all over the place yeah um
as a part of if if I mean there's a very
different conversation if somebody truly
has borderline personality disorder and
their emotional life feels like it's on
fire right that's a different
conversation trying to get somebody to
learn about how their emotions interact
with reality with the real world as well
as it's a different conversation when
you're talking to somebody who's
struggling with depression or anxiety
right so you're like I would start there
the second thing I would start with is
this does your wife know that she her
feel ings are very big on things whether
they're up or whether they're down can
youall agree on that yeah
okay will she trust
you um I I I mean she does trust me I
think to an extent your voice tells me
absolutely not even a little
bit um I think I think she trusts me but
I like I said she just has a hard time
seeing the bigger picture like that's
not what I'm asking for here asking
somebody who has borderline person
disorder asking somebody who's got
anxiety disorders to see a bigger
picture is is truly unfair especially at
the beginning what I'll often ask is
will you hold my hand do you trust me
and you watch somebody's shoulders drop
and they go I do and say
okay we've got to make a budget because
I don't feel safe okay and my body feels
like you're taking something from me
you're stealing something from me my
body feels like it's on fire I feel like
I hate you I feel like you're the
greatest person whatever that whatever
they're feeling great do you trust me
yes to make the next right choice for us
yes and that only works if they are
seeing a provider that they can get some
true um clinically based support and
help for right right and if you can't
get that basic level of trust then you
have to start asking yourself how can I
make sure that we are safe because we
can't work in Partnership together at
this moment we will someday but we can't
right now mhm does that make sense yes
and really I hope I'm not over
clarifying it but I'm trying to over
clarify it because you're allowing your
like I'm the backbone I got to do all
the stuff I got to make her happy with
all four of those Diagnostics you can
never be quote unquote happy right you
just gave every I've got a couple of
those Diagnostics dude sometimes I don't
care what I feel like I just got to do
the next right thing wow yeah so I
haven't spent my life trying to be happy
I've spent my life saying if I do these
things my body's going to feel good
at the end of the day does that make
sense right that took a lot of therapy a
lot of counseling my wife's pretty
amazing I have some great friends right
I had to do a whole lot of stuff to get
here yeah so don't try to solve it all
at once but I definitely would start
with getting a new um a new having a new
conversation do you have a particular
issue y'all are struggling with right
now I I mean we um I I just did the math
and we have over
$130,000 andt we don't even own a house
and uh we make okay money works parttime
I'm working two jobs right now how much
we're just trying to um before taxes and
everything I did the math we made
880,000 okay this year um I I one of my
jobs is uh 47 and the other one's about
15 and hers is 20 um that's all before
taxes and everything but we I just don't
even know where to start we did this
debt consolidation thing um which I just
feel like was a Band-Aid um it wasn't
actually you took a knife and stuck it
in the other leg that's what that was
and then I did a 4 I know 401k loan um
yeah then you took a knife and stuck it
in your arm yeah what else did you do we
we have a lot going on and I just
honestly I'm I lost I don't know where
to start and okay trying to get her on
page when I don't even know 100% what
I'm doing I just know we need to do
something so if she's got she's got
those challenges you know what she
senses she feels that you don't know
where you are on the map Jade's going to
walk you in the map but I want you to
hear this before she says anything Jade
had way way more debt than that me and
my wife we had way way more debt than
that that number you just gave me
doesn't scare me at all not a bit okay
right you just have to decide I'm gonna
go make this thing a
priority absolutely and your wife has to
make her healing a priority you get
those two things lined up man dude it's
game on yeah yeah yeah I mean what John
said is exactly it I I'm not blinking
when I hear $130,000 of debt I mean look
it's not good but it's right don't be
scared just go okay what it's like John
said what the next right thing that I
need to do and for you the next right
thing if you're not on a budget you need
to get on a budget are you on
one um I I did the free trial of the
every dollar and like we kind of walk
through a little bit together okay good
um so we're kind of working through that
a little bit figuring that out okay said
this is like new within the last couple
weeks okay good so Austin's gonna pick
up and after this call he's going to
give you a copy of my book money's not a
math problem and as part of that you're
gonna sign up and you're going to get
three months free of every dollar
premium because I think you need premium
that's going to help you walk through
this and you'll get three months free of
that to test it
out that's going to be everything
because this budget's going to tell you
what's what um I want you guys sitting
down and I want you to complete your
budget if you haven't already tonight
because you just getting a handle on the
numbers even if it's not good like right
even if you do that budget and you
realize man we're we're negative $75
every month no wonder there's a problem
just seeing it and knowing what it is is
still going to make you exhale and be
like all right I know what it is now I
see we have an income problem or you
might do that budget and realize hey we
have a decent amount it just looks like
we're spending too much and if that's
the case again you're going to Exhale
and know okay we've got a cut back on
our spending and so or it's a
combination of both and so just knowing
that is going to go okay I see what the
game plan is now we need to create a
plan of attack does that make sense yes
it does CU at the end of the day the
math is the same you still have to make
the payments and this is for anybody
listening debt doesn't go away unless
you make the payments you can't move it
over here you can't take out this loan
and cover it up with your mortgage you
have to actually make the payments and
for most of us that's called going out
and getting an oldfashioned j o okay you
can't get aside the work you have to put
on work boots do the work you have to
cut back your spending no more chilies
no more
Applebees you got to do the work you got
to make the sacrifice and trust and
believe it will show you can't do this
and kind of do it sneakily or do it
without anybody noticing you're going to
see it and you're going to feel it and
it's going to suck for a minute but then
you're going to be out of debt this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi /
[Music]
Ramsey you are listening to the Ramsay
show I am Jade this is John we're with
you for the next couple hours taking
your calls the number is 8825 5225 if
you want to give us a call I'm kind of
hype I'm not going to lie tomorrow is
Thanksgiving um I'm excited about that
but more than that my favorite part of
Thanksgiving is actually the day after
Thanksgiving not just because of the
leftovers John I can imagine the
leftovers in leftovers in your home are
pretty amazing are you cooking a spread
look they're on point I'm not going to
lie about that but more so I'm talking
about Black Friday I know Black Friday
come on do y'all go shopping for Black
Friday I go to the woods cuz I have
selfcontrol problems and so I just take
myself out of Internet range John you're
different man and I'm not mad at that
you're doing right but the rest of us
listen the other night I was having
dessert with my wife and I couldn't stop
and I literally took my fork and I just
hid it under the floor and she goes did
you do that on purpose and I go yeah but
I'm not EA you could stop eating the
dessert I could have I didn't want to
stop so I have to I have to put these
roadblocks in front of me man well what
was the dessert now we want to know what
it was do you know what it was just
sugar and goo and whatever I don't know
so John's in his house like Winnie the
Pooh just gobbling down bags of sugar
and honey I love it I love this time of
year man I love it me too not going to
lie Black Friday I love it um we're the
type we get up early we go out into
madness I love it I I will elbow
somebody for a air fryer in two seconds
I love the madness I save up a budget
and I put the line item and I I just get
wild I love it I don't know what it is
best buy I don't need anything at Best
Buy but I want to be there at 7: a.m.
going crazy it's just but here at Ramsey
Solutions we are also having a Black
Friday sale and the good thing is you
don't have to put anybody in a headlock
to get your deal cuz it's on the
interwebs John you can just roll over
pick up your phone and start clicking
you don't even have to get out of bed
but we've got Early Access to some of
our best deals of the year um you can
get meaningful gifts for your whole
family your friends everybody as low as
$8 that is nothing you're about to learn
this cuz you got a book coming out um
this is the time of year when Dave just
starts selling all your stuff and for
those of you who don't know we make a
commission off the sales price and we
always love it when Dave's like how
about five bucks thanks Dave thanks Dave
that's all right cuz his are on sale too
I mean you can get bestselling books
like The Total Money Makeover that's his
book so if he's putting it on sale for
$10 look we're all we're all being we're
in a little bit different place we're in
a little bit different place really I'm
just kidding of course you are uh baby
steps Millionaires and here's your book
John own your past chain your future for
for just $10 why not man why not that's
right put it uh put it for 70% off there
you go Financial Peace University I will
say this is my favorite one the fact
that you can get Financial Peace
University for under $60 is madness
sheer craziness um I tell folks all the
time the principles in Financial Peace
University are what helped my husband
and I pay off almost half a million
dollars of debt so technically this
product is worth half a million dollars
and you're getting it for 60 that's
crazy uh Rachel Cruz wallet is back
that's on sale and that's a product that
somehow is almost never on sale so the
fact that it's on sale is great and of
course questions for humans cards are on
sale cards starting at $10 so that's
pretty good so shop Black Friday if
you're not like me you don't want to go
out into the cold or out there with
crazy folks who will just cut you in
line just roll over in your bed turn on
your internet and log on to ramsy
solutions.com store and get yourself a
deal and get you some gifts for
everybody in your family but don't go
over budget doing it all right is that
cool cool with me let's go to the phone
lines we have Andrew and Sacramento
California what's going on
Andrew hey thank you for taking my call
how you guys doing we're doing good I'm
cutting up arey are you a Black Friday
dude like are you gonna go no I'm just
like you I'll go to the woods and hide
away he dud I love it you guys are good
good job how can we help so my question
is um I'm 32 I'm debt free besides my
mortgage I have my six months emergency
funds already put aside my question is
about the 15% retirement is that gross
is that like on top of your employer
sponsored or is that including your
employer sponsor what you to contribute
to that so you want it to be off of your
gross income
period okay so the and that's
it so gross incomes of putting money
into my employer sponsored if that
already equals close to
15% that's fine right there or should I
add more on top of that help me
understand tell me again so let me say
this let me so if you have if if your
employer has a match up to 5% and you
put in 5% and they put in 5% we want you
to put another 10% in and we want their
match to be gravy oh I see what you're
saying thank you John I was confused as
to what you're asking yeah no matter
what your company sponsored you were
always is doing 15% and the reason for
that there's a reason for that and that
is basically we just want you building
the habit of investing and the fact is
you might move on and go to another
company that offers no match or offers a
lower match or offers something
different at in way of benefits and we
don't we want your budget and your habit
used to no matter what I get I I invest
15% and so that's kind of the reasoning
behind that fair
enough yes and then my second question
was um I want to buy a second home but
I'm not sure if I should focus on paying
off this mortgage first before I start
saving up for another home because I
ultimately I want to make this house a
rental property and then move into my
forever home should I focus on paying
off this mortgage first or is it okay to
start saving up more money for my
forever home and then just have renters
end off paying this mortgage off yeah if
it were me I'd pay off your current home
first that's what we call baby step
seven is once you've paid that house off
and you're completely free and then
think about how much money you would
have saved up not having a mortgage that
you could quickly save up and pay cash
for another residence that you decide to
be a rental or maybe you move in that
one and make your current one a rental
you've got so many options the only
thing that I would say is whatever you
end up buying after your primary
residence buy it in cash
dude okay yeah so this is kind of like
the best thing I can just hear like w
yeah I know but hey hey this hey bro
this is exactly what I'm
doing okay okay we paid off the house
that we live in and now we're saving up
for um and it's and it dude it's the
worst man because we could go pull a
mortgage right now and I'm not putting
myself right back in that mess yeah and
I hate it because everything in my life
feels like it would be better if I just
did that except for the one thing which
would mean I'm back to being owned by a
bank and I don't like that I don't like
owned that's true Andrew you're 32 like
there's you know and you're not the only
one I think that there's just such this
Rush that we feel like I got to hurry up
and get this and I got to hurry up and
get my rental and I got to hurry up and
and I think some sometimes and I get it
like we all want to get to this
perceived place of success and like okay
like I made it with my money like we're
all trying to get there but we really
have to be careful in all of our getting
that we're also like getting the right
understanding and that we're doing
things correctly so that doesn't end in
Folly right because the worst thing ever
would be if you were like I'm so excited
to be rich and I'm so excited to be
successful that I don't pay off this
mortgage and I go get this other
mortgage and now you're racked with debt
and you thought you were going to rent
it out but your renters are kind of
wishy-washy and they're not paying and
then the roof breaks and then there's
earthquake like all these things that
have the ability to
happen there it will feel totally
different had you not gone into debt as
opposed to being strapped with debt and
I'm like you're in Sacramento so
whatever real estate you're talking
about buying is not going to be $100,000
is all I'm saying so to you don't want
that strap to you I would much rather
approach this knowing hey like I get to
control this and time is not pushing me
to do anything I make the call does that
make sense and I think that way you're
walking along that path and you're doing
it with the least amount of risk but
honestly the ultimate amount of reward
if you really think about it and we just
dude we just came out of a scenario
where I think in your
state it was illegal to evict people
even if they weren't paying during covid
that's show your right but that mortgage
still has to be paid right and so it's
not like we're just making this up for
fun yeah it's it's just we just take
call after call after thousands and
thousands of calls of people going what
do I do what do I do what do I do and
and that's a good point John we just we
just went through it that's a good point
it's not like we're trying to think of
every bad thing that could ever happen
no we just take the calls of the thing
the real things that do happen yeah and
the fact of the matter is most of our
best laid plans are with this assumption
that everything will go well even the
phrase I'm going to buy my dream home
dude no you're not yeah we don't know we
don't know you just don't know what's
going to happen and for that reason
alone I just love operating with as less
risk as I can that's right you know so
anyway um thanks for listening guys uh
that does it for this hour of the show
be sure to hang on with us John and I
will be back for the next hour this is
this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
I am join joined by Dr John delone who
is making silly faces at the camera if
you're watching on YouTube we're going
to take your calls all hour give us a
call the number Isle
88255 225 and we're going to try to help
you out hey it's the day before
Thanksgiving and I am excited um I've
actually been really on 10 this whole
month because John you got your your
fancy book out well I don't know how
fancy it is but I'm pretty proud of it
it's super fancy number one you're on a
cover and you're fancy and two the stuff
in it's awesome and three we sold a
bajillion redefining anxiety quick reads
and your book is way surpassing the way
mine got out so it's a pretty pretty
exciting man well it is exciting and you
can still pre-order it uh the actual
drop date as they say is not until
December so until then pre-order because
you get some cool things uh in the
process you get 3 months free of every
dollar premium which is the business if
I do say so myself so go ahead and
pre-order it today here's the thing
thing it's $10 like it's $10 you can't
even get you can't get anything for $10
anymore John that's two cups of coffee
two cups of coffee and not at Starbucks
cuz you don't even think about it cuz
Starbucks drinks are that's a cup and a
half at Starbucks okay $10 and you can
finally get to the bottom of why you
have not been able to stick to your
budget that is the number one question
Jade I made the budget just can't stick
to it or Jade I tried it but for some
reason it's just not working for me we
are getting to the bottom of that in
this quick read once and for all and by
the way it's called a quick read Because
you read it quick it's fast you can read
this thing in maybe two two and a half
hours if you're me it might take you
like 2:45 cuz I read a little bit slower
John I I don't know good about that if
um you are 55 and you make a good income
and you still can't figure out how to
hold together you can read it and if you
are 14 you can hand this to your kids
and say uh I want you to read this now
because you're going to by the time you
get there they're going to have some
other scheme they're trying to get you
on they're not going to be Bitcoin it's
going to be I don't know whatever
they're trading stuff animals toys
whatever read this so it's for everybody
it's awesome the book's called money's
not a math problem because it's not it
starts up here in the old Cranium that's
what we're talking about the things you
believe the lies that you believe and
anybody can read it it is me talking to
you it's not a bunch of facts and
numbers it's just it's just us talking
so pick up your copy today I would be so
grateful if you did or give it to
somebody as a gift they'd be so grateful
if you did let's go straight to the
phone lines we've got Len in Jackson
Florida my state home state what's going
on
lene hi I am I'm I'm calling to see if I
can get you all's opinion or advice on
whether or not I should sell my home
okay just a little background
information I purchased my home in
December of last year now this was
purchased prior to me finding the Dave
Ramsey steps okay I am on uh Ramsey step
number two I have
$95,000 in debt that is a mix of student
loans um and some cons consum debt there
do you mind breaking that down a little
bit further just so I can have a good
idea of it absolutely absolutely so um
70,000 for student loans okay and the
remainder would go to car which is about
1,500 not much left on that credit cards
and personal loans okay so 70,000 on
student loans not seven yes okay sorry
this HT 70,000 I Goa okay and then the
other the other uh 13,000 is various
things
yes credit cards and um yeah personal
personal MP okay keep going keep telling
us more you got it my take-home pay or
yes after insurance is taken out and 43b
Investments is around 6600 to about uh
8,000 a month and that is if I pick up
some extra shifts with another um
practice that I work with so my mortgage
uh is 3,600 a month okay and it's just I
want to get you all's advice on hey can
I buckle down and for sure just still
try to make tackle this debt or is it
best for me to go ahead and sell this
home so I can have more to be able to
put towards um the debt because again
about about
95,000 yeah um sheesh okay first thank
you for sharing all that cuz it's not
easy to get on the air and just lay it
be right so thank you um yes absolutely
so as it says yeah your your your
mortgage is more than half of your
income on a on a lower month those
months that you don't do the the extra
um the extra work you've got the 403b
contribution are you able to stop
that I can yeah okay how much how much a
month is going towards that 600 oh 600
okay that's helpful okay good I like to
hear that so now we're we're doing
better uh so now we're closer to 7,200
so I like that the the point is can we
find can we find another 20% of income
to keep coming in all the time so that
we can keep so that we can get this from
50% at least into the like 30% 29% range
because that that I can feel good with
does that make sense so we just found
$600 just in your 403 contribution and
by the way I'm not saying that this is
the situation for always this is just
temporary while we're paying the debt
off right fair so tomorrow I turn that
off i' turn that off instantly so you
can get that money back um and then if
you add your overtime work we're getting
there right so
obviously that's not Su like nobody
wants to work overtime the rest of their
life John so the next part is we've got
to get this debt paid off and then we've
got to get our income up is there a
trajectory that you see your income
going up longterm that's not you
overtime and side hustling
not currently what do you do for a
living a nurse
practitioner you're telling me there's
not a job trajectory for you as a nurse
practitioner again remember we're just
looking for 25% we're looking for 25%
more money
right and you're you're you're paying to
a 403b are you working a
nonprofit yes correct okay are you at a
university no
no no can I like I hear in your voice
that you're trying you want us to tell
you to sell this
house no I mean honestly I love my home
I I really do it's just a matter of you
know I'm already trying to work some
extra shifts as um outside of my primary
role so that I can get that extra income
so then it becomes okay how else can I
bring in some extra income to really
make a dent in the in the debt I have
missed this and truthfully obviously I
want to pay it off as soon as possible I
may need to be a bit more patient be a
bit more realistic in it you know going
away but me and me and Jay don't like
patient we like to just get stuff done
what what um if you sold this house
right now what would you
pocket um I purchased price was 415
currently it's looking at about
440 okay so after your realator fees you
you wouldn't take home a ton but it' be
some right right
right this is tough look at the end of
the day you can look at this equation I
love I honestly I I love my home I would
love to stay in it but at the same time
you know I want to be able
to feel like it's paycheck to pay right
I get it and the thing is you've got one
of two paths here you can either find a
way that you're earning 20% more right
because again the 25% is off your gross
it's not your gross after your
deductions right so you we found some of
it with the 600 you got to find 20 %
more income and you have to ask yourself
is this me getting my career up over
time or am I not going to find the 25%
and I'm going to get out of this house
the choice is yours this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home by High Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from Church
Hill gives you an advantage over those
other guys go to Churchill mortgage.com
today to learn
[Music]
more
what's going on this is the Ramsey Show
I'm Jade warshot this is Dr John deloney
on the right of me and we are taking
your calls all afternoon long give us a
call 8825 5225 is the number I will talk
to you about the things that have to do
with your money and John will jump in on
that cuz he knows the stuff too but uh
he's the guy that's going to help you
with the relational stuff what's going
on all the other stuff right I feel like
money is almost it's never just money
right it's always always something going
on there always something going on and
we'll help you with that so give us a
call um we'd be happy to have you on the
line let's go to the lines we've got
Laken in Nashville O Nashville Tennessee
in the Ville what's going on
Laken how are you guys we're doing good
how can we help
you well I was just curious of how I
could do better what I could change I
don't know if I'm missing something but
I'm 23 I'm a student I work part-time I
don't have any debt um I have some money
in 401k and I have some stocks I have uh
$2,500 in a high Y savings account and
then about
3,500 just in a regular savings account
okay and so I'm just wondering what else
I could be doing how old did you say you
are 23 okay what's your living
situation I live with a roommate um in a
just a little town home cool cool cool
and what's your job what are you what
are you earning because you're doing a
good job an excellent job thank you I'm
uh I work at Starbucks I'm a BRAC so I
get uh free tuition stents so don't have
to pay for school I I make about $800 a
month with everything taken out and then
through college my parents give me
$1,300 a month okay so you got kind of a
combined situation there because I was
going to say how did you manage to save
this money making $800 a month but we
got a little allowance here for Mom and
Dad I'm not mad that what are you
worried about you're you're winning
across every metric for every college
student I
know well I wouldn't necessarily say I'm
worried I just want to put myself in a
really good position my parents have
done a good job of preparing their lives
for me and my sister and helping us out
and I want to be able to do that
starting now just for my future and then
my kids future and just setting up like
my whole family line on a good
trajectory so I don't know what else I
can be doing look I'm giving you a slow
clap I'm just giving you the Mighty
Ducks slow clap because I just love that
you're thinking like this do you
understand at 23 think generation
dude my brain cells were not doing that
at 23 and I'm so grateful that you are
um hey let's walk through what you told
me no debt excellent um you told me
you've got a 401k through Starbucks
that's great um and you're contributing
to that and then you told me you've got
uh about 6,000 bucks saved some of it's
in a high yield and some of it's just in
a regular savings how much you got in
stocks um I just have like a $1,000 in
stocks um all that's been free Starbucks
like gives us stocks every year um and
then in my 401k I have like just about
15,000 a little over that 15 grand in a
401 really wow M so look again I'm just
very very good shook so um very good
what I would do is the only I'm just
going to walk through and just literally
be a fine- toothed comb because you're
doing such a great job the the money you
have saved I'd probably put it all in
the high yield savings account just so
you can get a better r of return they're
pretty high right now so that's good and
for what I'm just going to call that is
I'm going to call that your 3 to six
month expenses right CU it covers your
your rent for a couple of months how
much is your rent by the
way um well my portion would come out to
maybe uh
1300 like all the utilities and whatnot
okay so what I would do is I would get
sit down with a calculator or sit down
with your budget and calculate out what
your expenses are like basic I'm not
talking about the budget with all the
bells and whistles I'm talking about
just the basic expenses it takes for you
to get you know to live if you were to
lose your job create find out what the
number is for 6 months of expenses and
that's your next goal that's what I want
you to save up you've got 6,000 now what
do you need to put with it in order for
that to happen the stocks you know we're
not really stock people around here it's
kind of one of those risky things so I
probably it's not like you're buying it
right they're just giving it to
you yeah yeah you know at some point if
you're ready to cash it out because
you're trying to buy a house or
something great do that um right now the
house is not on fire so I'm not like
sell them sell them immediately but what
I do want you to come away from this
conversation is that if you're going to
buy investment stocks are not what I
would tell you to buy right I'd want you
to buy mutual funds or ETFs that have a
lot a lot in it right we're not going to
do single stocks cuz that's the riskiest
way to invest so learn that from this
conversation um I love that you have
your 41k um technically you're a little
ahead of yourself because you started
investing before you've gotten your 3 to
6 months saved right now you've got
about 3 months saved so I'm not going to
tell you to stop but I want you to get
up to six months saved because I think
that's just going to be best for you cuz
it's only you and you're working at
Starbucks and Mom and Dad let's be
honest are providing more than half of
your income so let's bump that up very
actively and other than that good job
you know after this my next next big
goal would be when do you graduate by
the
way um I graduate I believe in a year
and a half okay cool all goes to plan
you're a
junior yes you know I was actually
looking online for the past like I don't
know six months of internships with
Randy Solutions because I look so close
yeah keep looking come on over here yeah
keep send an email to HR because we want
people like you around here and I'll
tell you this you've got a bunch of
investment vehicles I want you to move
to the very top of your investment list
you you are the person I want you to
means here's what it means make sure you
get out of college 18 months from now
and you don't owe anybody anything make
sure you have done every internship you
can get your hands- onade coffee in
every meeting room you can get in ask
your professors hey is there a way that
I could get invited to this I want to
see this can I work behind backstage at
the Showcase whatever the thing is leave
no stone unturned so that when you
graduate uate you don't owe anybody
anything and you have a slate of
experiences to lay down in front of a
future employer and say I've already
been there I'm ready to rock and roll
and so you're investing in experiences
that I mean you're so I can't tell you
the number of adults that we talk to who
are 50 and 60 that don't have $155,000
in the fall on you're so far ahead so
far so your investment is in you you
okay I want you to be ready to run and
Gun 18 months from now and you walk
across that stage and you're already
searching internships man good grief
people who are worried about next
Generation need to talk to people like
Laken I know that's right my dog has a
unlock we're we're going to be we're
going to be all right AES she's going to
be great wow look at this John I yeah I
am if she was looking for a goal
probably my next goal would be to not
have to accept any money from my parents
that would be the next thing on my
Horizon it's like okay they're giving
her this um stipend or you know
allowance per se now while she's in
school that's nice of them to do that
that when she goes out graduates gets
her big girl job it's like okay cut them
out and now honestly the next thing for
her to do is save up to buy a home save
up for a down payment and you know she's
set her this is why we teach it John
this is why because she I look at this
and I go man if at 23 my life would be I
mean you can't really say it like that
because what we go through makes us who
we are but my point is this is what I
want for my kids right this right here I
don't want them to have to make the dumb
mistakes that I made with debt um I want
them to be set up like this and it's
like hey what do I want to do next the
world's my oyster you know and think of
it this way parents sometimes we think
that if we take all the we clear all the
struggles out of the way so that our
kids can have the fastest quickest path
from from wherever we are to success and
sometimes we try to clear all the
hurdles because we have some guilt we
were working when they were young we
didn't have couldn't buy them all the
stuff when they were little we had to
cancel the Athletics uh cuz we couldn't
for the travel Sports one year whatever
and we try to clear the path I want you
to think of it like this it's like going
into a gym and your kid is in there
exercising to get stronger and you take
all the weight off the bar for him it's
not helping them out it's not helping
them get stronger it's helping them go
to the gym and think they're getting
stronger and they're actually getting
they're either staying the same or
they're getting a little bit
weaker but like her parents have done
they've told her you're going to have a
job yep and you're going to work and
you're going to make good grades and
you're going to do internships you're
going to graduate and we're going to
help you a bit so you're not taking the
weight off the bar but you are spotting
them oh yeah and that's what good
parents do right they don't clear the
deck they walk alongside you right or
they walk right behind you right awesome
job all around I love it man you're way
ahead of the game lak well done this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them SM smarter
and make better decisions and level up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you are listening to the ramsy show
thanks for hanging out with us today I
am Jade warshaw your host joined by your
other host his name is Dr John delone
and we are here with you hanging out all
afternoon long we'd love if you gave us
a call the number is8
825-5222 the easiest way to find expert
local help is to download the neighborly
app where you can find Services schedule
appointments and get exclusive special
offers and discounts download the
neighborly app now to get started all
right today's question comes from
Rebecca in Alabama Rebecca writes my
25-year-old sibling is married with
three kids six three and three months
the couple has never had consistent
employment and one is currently a
stay-at-home parent persons had multiple
job opportunities within walking
distance even some that offer free child
care but they refused to work during the
entirety of their marriage they have
both begged and borrowed for everything
they have they continue to make very
poor financial decisions that have
caused them to be behind on rent and car
payments in order to play catchup they
took out a personal loan with their
place of employment that will now cost
them more than their original rent each
month they've borrowed thousands from
family members claiming to need it for
bills but the bills never get paid at
this point the children are deeply
suffering from the from the consequences
of their parents' poor
choices in what way could an outsider
help the situation I'm seriously
considering calling CPS but that doesn't
change their financial or long-term
situation is this something I should
come to terms with and let it work
itself out any advice on helping someone
that is oblivious to their
wrongdoings um man this is a mess so I'm
just going to go order of importance
when it comes to children I simply don't
mess around with that my friends know
that my family knows that my colleagues
know that I do not mess around with this
because it's your brother or sister it's
a
sibling um I before I called CPS I would
probably take them out for coffee and
say I'm offering to take your three kids
in for a period of two or three months
while you get your crap together I will
call CPS if you decline this option well
wait can I ask you yes what point
because we know it's bad but we don't
know what that means yeah let me let me
clarify the children are deeply
suffering I want to know what that means
that that's right and I want to know at
what point you John would be like that
do that whole thing of I'm taking you
for coffee BL if I find out kids are
missing meals if I find out kids are
walking around the street at 11:00 at
night CU mom and dad are watching TV if
I find out kids uh three-year-olds are
spending the night in Neighbors garage
is which I've heard about because they
don't have they can't get back in the
house I'm calling like the heat's off
the Air's off like right if Mom and Dad
are leaving at night and leaving the
six-year-old in charge of the
three-month-old kind of stuff I'm
calling I'm either going to offer your
kids going to come stay with me you have
two you have two choices there is no
choice here over the next 60 days where
they stay with you I'm with that yeah um
now deeply suffering if it's Mom and Dad
are sitting there watching
TV I parent differently than that it
frustrates me and makes me makes me
upset they're not deeply suffering sure
right if they're having meals but
they're not organic foods they're
they're not deeply suffering right so um
I want to be very clear about this but
assuming the things that I've I've run
across in my professional career kids
are are are struggling I'm going to put
a very clear thing so when it comes to
kids I don't mess around with that I
don't play with that kids are very very
important um the second thing is any
advice on helping someone that is
oblivious to their wrongdoings I reject
that they're not oblivious they're doing
exactly what works because everyone in
their life keeps giving them money
period so they're not oblivious
why in the world would you work if
family members keep giving you thousands
and thousands of dollars for you to do
whatever you want with it um and by the
way family members if you have a family
member that comes to you and says hey I
really need help to the tune of
thousands of dollars to pay bills and
you are able to help what I would say is
I give me the number to the the light
bill place and I'll call and pay it give
me the number to whatever I will buy you
a grocery card at Kroger or Publix or
whatever and we'll take care of it that
way you're not just forking over giving
you thousands of dollars right cuz then
I'm contributing right oh 100% so um
that's number two um let's take kids off
the table cuz kids is a whole different
ball game yeah let's take kids off the
table clearly mom and dad are
contributing to this clearly other other
family members are contributing to this
so in what way can an outsider help a
situation like this where they have a
sibling that Mom and Dad are continuing
to let make poor decisions or cousin or
what
nothing nothing yeah and I think one of
the hardest things we can do is watch
people we love make decisions that we
know are hurting them yeah you want to
try to get in there and fix it you can't
you haven't been invited in what you can
do is make sure when the Call Comes and
it will that you have your boundaries in
order you have your house in order
you're working on you and your marriage
and your finances and your parenting so
when the Call Comes and it will MH can
you help that you're in a place that you
can help and that help is not going to
be I'm gonna give you a bunch of cash it
might be I'll take out and help map out
a budget with you I'll take and give you
some hard truth about y'all got to go to
work but I we're we already decided
we're going to stay at home with our
kids you can't afford to stay at home
with your kids right I might do that but
I'm going to work on me right now oh
that's so hard you're you're exactly
right but that is I I sympathize with
this person it's so my heart it breaks
my heart cuz you're like okay I'm
supposed to sit back like this and like
I got to take my hands off the situation
because they won't let me like you said
they won't let me in how do you make
peace with that and there's no peace I
experienced this personally there is no
peace there's no peace you're just like
waiting it's a death it's a loss yeah so
it's it's a g it's grieving it's pure
grief and by the way I think that one of
the great cancers of our current culture
is everybody trying to insert themselves
into situations families they hav they I
haven't asked for your help yeah you
can't fix it do it do it this way do it
this way I I haven't I haven't helped if
instead of people going home and looking
in the mirror and saying I'm make sure
my house is in order I'm going to make
sure my spiritual life my financial life
my physical life my marriages in order
so that when people invite me in I'm
ready well then there's the other side
of that John like they might blow
themselves up exactly right and like
there might we hope there's a the a
bright side that comes along but they
might blow themselves up that's exactly
right and so um you have to make some
space for that that's one of the things
I learned training with the SWAT guys is
we're going to train with every every
minute of every day so that we have a
positive outcome
and because we can't control what other
people decide to do we're going to
create a little bit of space for if this
whole thing goes sideways and that's a
heartbreaking thing to realize that I
can't control everything but this person
is trying to how do I insert myself into
this and fix it and I would lovingly
tell them you can't wow and so then for
the person who's listening who's like
man I've been there I sat I did the
thing I I took my hands off the wheel
because they weren't letting me help
they weren't letting me get in and help
them drive to get there and they they
did implode the thing and and it is bad
and now I feel guilty cuz I'm wondering
was there anything was there anything I
could have done yeah what what do you
say to the person who's got
guilt I mean you hold that guilt you
hold it I mean you hold that guilt and
it moves I mean guilt is a it's a
natural thing but should they even feel
guilt like should they I I don't I I I
doing the right thing I haven't been
able to figure out how to not quote
unquote feel guilt I can choose to not
head into resentment and so that means I
intend will turn left and head into
guilt instead of heading into I just am
so mad at you all the time um I'm going
to choose to say hey you're an adult you
you're running your life I'm not going
to participate in this um but I'm going
to be heartbroken I'm going to feel I'm
always G to ask myself and may be right
in my letter and just say I love you
guys and when you're ready to change
your life I'm here to help that's all
you can do uh but that's that's what you
can do but I I haven't found a way
especially initially to not feel that
guilt like yeah you can't like
rationalize can't rationalize it away
yeah for sure oo this is tough this is a
tough one I hate it I wish that we could
don't we all right wish that we could go
to our loved ones and tell them to live
their life like we want them to live it
well yeah there's that that's the thing
like some people that's the hard part
people's lives are going to look
different than yours and in this case it
does smell bad like it looks like there
is some real real issues going on I
don't think this person's being dramatic
I don't think that it's when she says
deeply suffering based off of what she
said financially and with their jobs
employment I think that's the case and
it's just I mean the fact is it's like
you're watching a car crash and you
can't look away even if you look away
you still hear it going on right it's
like there's no way to get away from it
so I feel for them I really do yeah but
we we live we live in a world where
there's different paths people can take
and I think we also live in a world that
says we should everyone should take the
same path as us and I don't think that's
right no that's not right and at the
same time man it just it's heartbreaking
when people we love Yeah are head headed
to ruin talking about some stuff on the
ramsy show today what we get into all of
it relationships the money we are not
afraid to take your call whatever it is
so stick with us this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
this is the ramsy show I'm Jade warshaw
your host joined by your other host his
name is Dr John deloney he's sitting
right here to my right we're going to
take your calls all afternoon please
give us a call the number is8
825-5222 coming out in January the book
is called Breaking Free from broke I
actually think I have it here for those
watching I can show you what it looks
like because I think that this I don't
know the cover is just unique I really
really like it um we want you to
pre-order this book today you can
pre-order it it's just $20 right but
when you pre-order it you get $100 in
free bonus items so you get access to a
talk that he's done it's called show me
the money I've heard the talk it's
legitimate so you want to get that it's
going to help help you so much and you
get a free Q&A with George you get
access to the audio book and the ebook
plus you get a very very special offer
with every dollar you get three months
of every dollar premium that's like the
Crim de la Crim 3 months for free so
that's pretty legitimate it says the
world is filled with money traps and
distractions designed to keep you
brainwashed and in debt with undeniable
research and data George exposes is the
most common money myths and excuses
headon so he's talking about things like
credit card schemes he's talking about
uh investment traps he's talking about
mortgage myths this is all the stuff
he's going over and I like George
because he's kind of like like he's like
Inspector Gadget like he gets in there
and finds out everything that's going on
I'm the type of person I'm like H it's
too much to read all the books and like
look underneath the mattress and he does
all that for you yeah he's the guy that
reads uh literally the fine print and
then calls the company he's like hey you
said in section 4 2A that I could have
this for free and they're like okay man
so yeah he goes he knows the bylaws yes
and when somebody says that's not real
dude he can't sleep until he either
realizes he's wrong or yes it is yeah he
gets the bottom D this book pulls every
excuse and just throws in the trash it's
incredible that's right read it what I
think you should read it because at
every conversation any debate someone's
going to try to debate you at money
you're just mic drop them every time
after you read this book so I suggest it
it's on pre-order remember it's $20 the
book is Breaking Free from broke you can
get it on Rams solutions.com or anywhere
they sell fine fine what is it fine
reading reading material yeah fine
reading material so pick up your copy
today let's go to Los Angeles California
we've got Dana on the phone line what's
going on
Dana hi uh so I I am 29 years old and
I've been planning to purchase a home
home but I'm planning to like purchase
it with my brother so is it a smart idea
to like have my brother as a co-owner of
the property I mean majority of the down
payment is going to come from me and so
is mortgage yeah no um nope nope nope no
how old did you say you
were I'm 29 29 29 okay why can I just
can I understand why why are you guys
doing this together what's the purpose
in your
mind um we've been living together
um like for like three years and we've
been planning to purchase a property to
as well why is my question
um because well we just we we we're like
both single and we don't know like we
wanted to stop renting and we wanted to
have like our own property so this is
your way you felt like you couldn't
afford it separately so you're doing it
together is that
accurate uh yes I think I mean
personally I like with the current
housing market I don't think I can
afford like the monthly mortgage well
let's look at it what do you make every
what do you make every month what's your
take home pay I make around uh around
every month yeah yeah around 6 6,200
6,200 yes that's your take-home pay okay
so what type of home are you trying to
buy like when you when you say here's
what I need
and you're realistic about what your
needs are and you're not going overboard
what was what does a cost a home like
that cost you in Los Angeles CU I know
it's going to be
expensive yeah um since I'm single like
maybe like a condo or a town house like
with like two bed like a single bedroom
like I'm just like living alone sure
that's fair enough what what would that
cost you in the area that you
live um in the area you're trying to be
looking yeah it's around like 4 50 to
five 5 I think no I 450 to 600 okay so
450 to 600 that's a big range um and
then my next question is what kind of
work do you
do I work in a as a lab scientist in the
hospital a lab scientist okay here's
thanks for giving me the particulars I
don't think that you should like John
said I don't think that you should buy a
home with your brother there's a lot
that can go wrong there um it would be
different if one of you were purchasing
the home and one of you put the down
payment on and said hey if you want to
live here and pay me rent or pay for
your room here you could do that um
doing that yeah that's that's fine um
the the hard part comes
when it's you're dating somebody and
you're ready for them to move out and
now they feel like they got the raw end
of the deal like there are many things
that can go wrong and I just want to
call that out so and and there's one
other thing when you're married there's
a and you get divorced there is a
business there's a Le path towards
separation that's why we same reason we
tell people don't um buy a house with
your boyfriend or girlfriend because the
separation Isn't So Clean it's a
mess and similarly if you and your
brother just go in as as brother and
sister boyfriend
girlfriend um just two people the
separation part is going to be a
disaster not to mention Are you
seriously sis you're going to make me
pay you back for your down payment well
yeah are you kidding me I'm your brother
you don't love me well yeah or vice
versa right and so or he's he's going to
start dating someone and bringing them
to your house and she's not going like
the way you cook and dude I just I just
wouldn't I just wouldn't I wouldn't and
here here's the greatest way you can
love each other is to not go into a
legally binding agreement together see
what I'm saying right one of you buy the
house and rent it rent a room to the
other one I'm fine with that mhm and and
and do it right like even when you do
way John said do a leas like this is is
it a year lease let's just start with a
year-to-year thing right and and and do
it by the book so that at the end of the
day if something has to if the hammer
has to come down it's not it's not you
doing it it's the lease right you know
what I'm saying like hey the lease is up
we did say and you can always point back
to the terms of what you guys agreed on
I'm not going to lie I still don't love
it but it's your life if you want live
with your brother I'm not mad at it um I
just went into it man that's all I can
say um at the end of the day I here's
here's also where I stand though with
purchasing a house there is a piece of
this whether it was let's say you didn't
have a brother and let's just say you
were calling and your Hope was to get a
roommate to live in the house it bothers
me for somebody to own a home that they
can't pay for in full on their own
because like I said something can happen
and whoever is living with you moves out
and it could take you a longer a longer
period of time than you thought it would
to find a replacement and so now you've
got to be able to cover the mortgage do
you see what I'm saying so my goal here
is to get you thinking about every angle
of this thing and just with me poking a
few holes I don't love it like I look I
want you to have a condo I want you to
have a home I I want you to not be a
renter but I I want it to be done in the
right way my question for you next is
what would it look like and this is just
for you to brainstorm uh you don't have
to answer this now where you live is
really expensive what does it look like
for you to do the same typee of work
elsewhere uh I can move I guess but uh I
feel like my current job right now is
really good like benefits wise I it is
but it's not allowing you to live you
want a home and it's not allowing you to
do that look I I have family who lived
in California for years and they're
married and at one point they said she's
a teacher and the other one you know
Works in gaming and they said we're
never going to have the life we want
here and they picked up and moved to
Georgia
yeah all I'm saying is you may have to
consider our hospitals need lab
scientists in Kansas City right where
you can buy a condo maybe for 300
instead of 600 or maybe 350 instead of
what and I don't know Kansas people are
going to be like you can't but I don't
know but all to say is you have to
decide which dream we want which dream
that's so true John oo that's a hard one
but she's got some options she's just
got to allow herself to see the options
this is the r
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships wow my voice really
cracked on that I'm Jade warshaw joined
by puberty gets us all
eventually oh my goodness thank you John
delone joined by my co-host Dr John
delone we're taking your calls the
number is
88255 225 I'm just excited because it's
Thanksgiving I think my voice went into
higher registers than usual because of
that let's be honest about that you can
just go with whatever store you want to
that is right but we're happy to be here
with you guys give us a call uh we are
going to help you with the things that
are going on in your life and your money
that's what we're going to do here with
Woody from Bowling Green Kentucky what's
going on what's going on Woody hey can
you hear me we got you what's up Woody
I'm on a I'm on a flip phone I'm
oldfashioned we're oldfashioned too
perfect what's up man okay uh yeah uh my
girlfriend's having uh well I found out
a well I think I lost still go sorry
that was on me sorry about that Woody
okay okay get okay uh so she's getting a
heart transplant and then I found out
she getting a kidney
transplant she has yeah she's on the
she's on the list and they're looking
for one right now wow that's a that's a
fullon that's like a a new body yeah
that's a chip and Joanna makeover that's
all the way to the studs man what H
what's going on yeah and so uh and
that's then at St Thomas is where they
gonna do
this and I mean they're looking for
they're looking uh right now and it
could happen at any time I guess and it
might not not but you don't you just
don't know but anyway uh the question is
am I responsible for her medical
bills this is the
concern well I well let me tell you in
life work and family work comes first
family comes second and why that is if
you ain't got no money the family's
going to leave anyway wait a minute no I
think you got that backwards brother but
no no no well when you under the bridge
down there and they say daddy what's
going on who who said Daddy what's going
on Woody Woody pull back hold back hold
back for a second hold up hold up thank
you um it's interesting to me that this
your girlfriend how long has she been
your girlfriend number one please say
six weeks
please 20 years 20 20
years yeah
Woody why haven't you married her
yet uh I'm Catholic
what I even more reason to marry her
because I know y'all living
together yeah well you were some help me
no no uh uh I've been married one time
she been married one time and we just
rather not woody you've been married for
20 years to this woman I know right you
can pretend all you want and play
whatever semantic games but you've been
as married as as any other married folks
have been right everybody thinks that
everybody says that they keep calling my
wife I said she's not my wife yes she
she is more your wife why why do you
feel that way I'm trying to understand
why you feel that way why you don't want
to go all the way take it to the Limit
you ever heard the song The warer yes
yes that's me you hey Woody you watch
you watch too much yellow stone is what
you do woody is a rolling stone guys all
right so hey Woody that is your like
Woody she's your wife and you can call
her whatever you want to she's your wife
yeah um let me ask you this let me ask
you this and this is all
seriousness okay if I had a friend I'm
thinking of I have a particular friend
in my mind just a friend a buddy of mine
okay a guy that I grew up with if that
dude lived with me for 20 years yeah it
was just my my my ride or die friend
and he had to go to the hospital and
have just a complete transmission change
right yeah I would I I not obligation
but as my brother I would participate in
helping where I could I I'm I'm struck
by your
question yeah because she is your wife
you can call it what you want she's your
wife you've been together for 20 years
living together yeah do you not want to
pay you don't want to help like what's
what's the where's what's the root of
the question well the trouble is the
money the money is not there well does
she then what then why ask the question
it don't matter what you're obligated if
you don't got it you don't got it I mean
she has
Insurance yeah she got the uh human and
Medicare whatever and so do we know have
you guys talked with them to know okay
what is this going to cost like what's
your out-of-pocket maximum is she doing
stuff that is above and beyond her
coverage do you guys know what that is
because those are real questions I do
want you to ask uh we're not going to
aim mhy she she wants to why we're
trying well because we want her to have
the heart and the kidney well yes the
money don't mean nothing it does don't
you know it does mean something Woody
I'm G challenge you on that because she
she has Insurance all you need to do is
call him up today and say hey my
girlfriend is having this procedure
mylaw wife um you know as as far as we
know like she's going to the doctors and
stuff that she's supposed to do what's
our per year what's the maximum we're
going to pay per year cuz this is going
to be some ongoing treatment what's the
maximum we pay per year and they might
say something like $7,000 or $4,000 or
$10,000 but knowing is good then my next
question is has she been working does
she have any money
anywhere that's that's where I come in
at okay so your money
bags I'm I provide her a roof and food a
roof and food okay yeah I mean it's uh
when when I found out that she was sick
actually we had we was getting ready to
part part ways kind of Butz I I travel a
lot and you know we get along great and
she watched the house for me make sure
nobody don't steal nothing you know what
I'm saying and Wy you're describing
you're describing my dog Rose and this
is not the first time y'all have tried
to part ways let's be honest about that
you keep ending up together my country
dog watches the house while we're gone
yeah yeah well she's been she's had a
rough a rough I say a rough life and it
just she's been with you for 25 to 30%
of it I know it and it
just hey do you love her do you love her
or are you just with her out of
convenience and out of I'm comfortable
both it's both I guess hey let me ask
you this brother just just just guy to
guy nobody's listened to us except for a
couple of million people yeah what what
are you afraid of Are You Afraid about
your lose the person that you
love uh
both no I want you to be honest and
we've been cling around I want you be
honest are you terrified that you're
about to lose your best friend and oh oh
No Doubt no doubt okay I mean you we've
been you know we've been through several
things both of us preia and it just uh
and I know how this world Works none of
us get out of it alive the lawyers don't
care no I hey we're we're not passing
none of this crap on off to the lawyers
this is about you being my brother one
state over a grown man not putting your
head in the sand when something scary is
coming up up against the woman you love
you're going to do what Jade said once
you call the hospital get some numbers
on this thing it's not about am I
responsible for her bills the woman I
love might die I'm going to do what I
can and she's not a pet she's not
somebody watches the house she's the
woman of the last quarter Century of
your life let's see what we can do with
some real numbers and some real action
and let's support that woman we'll be
right
[Music]
back
you're listening to the ramsy show I am
Jade warshaw joined by Dr John deloney
we are taking your call so give us a
call 8825 5225 is how you can reach us
by the way if you're a new listener and
if you want to dive deeper into the
Ramsey Baby Steps you can go ahead and
go to ramseys solutions.com and click on
that get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next steps for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you're at today so if you are new head
over to ramseys solutions.com and click
get started we love if you did that
let's go straight to the phone lines
Richmond Virginia we've got Brion on the
line Hi how are you guys doing today
doing well how are you uh I'm doing all
right just getting a little stressed
okay I feel that what's going on um so
my situation is a little two-part um
I've been listening long enough um to
know a little bit of how to get out of
debt but I I'm I keep starting budgets
and don't know how to stick to them and
then they kind of fall apart life
happens uh and the second part of that
is I know the easiest way is to increase
income um and in my position I keep
hitting this brick wall of you're
overqualified and don't have enough
experience in stuff like grocery or you
know trying to pick up uh extra shifts
at like a local restaurant doing server
work or that kind of stuff so I I don't
know how to they're saying you're
overqualified when you try to get that
extra jobs I see I've had a McDonald's
tell me face to face yeah you're way
over qualified to ever work here do you
tell them hey this is not my be all end
all I'm just trying to make some extra
cash um I have told some
yes all of than that so hey before Jade
answers because she Jade's Jade's just
the Guru at walking people through this
in both of the scenarios you just
painted you you've kind of cornered
yourself as this as this tragic victim
in this
story and you owe a whole bunch of money
and you're running up against some
roadblocks but I want you to you got to
change your psychology on this or it's
just always going to be too heavy does
that make sense it does like you're it
feels like you're going through life and
life keeps happening to you instead of
you saying No this is my one precious
Reckless life and I'm going to live it
all the way I'm going to go all in right
and that means like I'm not going to let
an assistant manager at McDonald's tell
me I'm overqualified I'm going to
convince them I need to work and I'm
going to work harder than anybody you
got on staff and I got 15 you see what
I'm saying like it's just a matter of
I'm not I I just refuse to be a victim
in this story and so I want you to
change your psychology there and Jade
will walk you through it she's the she's
the goat at this um but let's let's
throw your shoulders back man stand up
tall and like we're going to go head on
and deal with this problem hey how old
are you I'm 32 okay 32 and what's your
what's your your real
job um so I'm a full-time videographer
okay videographer and is it your
business or you work for a company I
work for a company okay so what would it
look like if if if you really are
getting these doors closed in your face
if I were in your shoes I'm always one
that if I'm looking for some side hustle
work I'm going to do the thing that's
directly related to what I already know
how to do because I probably already
have connections I already know I love
doing it and I can charge more because
I've cut out the middleman you know what
I'm saying so what would it look like
you going out and getting some clients
and you videoing some weddings and you
being at the bar mitzvah or whatever it
is are you able to do that say again so
it's funny you say that I do that on the
side um and it just it doesn't bring in
enough for me to I have kids I guess I
left that part out I have kids how many
um and so it's kind of four is it just
you or do you have a wife uh I'm
divorced okay so you're saying it's a
time is it a time constraint is that the
problem um not so much as a time
constraint as much as um I save money
and then you know kids need new clothes
or new shoes or right but that's a
budgeting issue that's a budgeting issue
and we'll talk about that are the kids
with you fulltime or do you guys split
at 50/50 how does that work um they're
with Mom full-time and I'm kind of at
this point I'm the cash cow okay dude
you go again there you go back into your
like a corner quit me in the cash cow
well you wait a minute because yeah you
have four kids you need to pay for them
oh absolutely okay I just wanted to the
way you said it made it seem like you
were kind of mad that you had to pay for
your kids I'm just saying the way it
came across you might not have Meed that
way I forgive you no not at all okay
moving
on moving on here's what I number one I
wholeheartedly agree with John because
it's kind of like I tried this I hit a
wall it didn't work work wo was me I
tried this I hit a wall it didn't work
wo was me rarely will it work the first
time like usually you have to keep
swinging and swinging and knocking and
knocking and kick these doors down cuz
nothing gets just and you you know this
nothing is handed to you and nothing is
free and no almost nothing is easy you
know and so I really want you to go hey
I like look in your look in the mirror
tonight and go this is going to be
hard this is going to be really hard and
once you've just been real with yourself
it's like okay now let's go this is not
going to be easy this is a season and
it's going to be tough once you admit
that then it's like We're Off to the
Races so keep knocking on the door doing
the videographer work then go get you an
instacart job too now you're making more
money I want you on a budget here we do
an every dollar budget um I want you to
download it you can download it for free
on your own tonight and then once you
have the budget those things that are
what I would call just normal monthly
expenses that come up will no longer be
these things that throw you off your
game and you're having to dig into your
savings because on the every dollar
budget you'll be able to say okay I
bring in an x amount of dollars each
month so how much money do you bring in
each
month uh about three 3,000 after taxes
and insurance perfect so at the top of
your budget it'll there's a place for
you to put income you'll put $3,000 then
there's a place where you can list
everything that you could ever think of
spending money on in a month and it will
do the math for you so you're going to
spend that three ,000 on paper or on
digital paper on purpose so December's
coming up I want you to say okay I'm
making a budget for December how am I
going to spend this $3,000 and it's
you're starting with the four the four
basic walls right your your rent and
your transportation and your utilities
and your food that's first and then you
go back through the next most important
items and then you make sure to write
all the things that your kids might need
and look at their feet do they need new
shoes if you see okay the shoes are
getting worn out I'm going to start
putting aside a little bit of money for
that but when you give this money a plan
suddenly it's like okay I see where it's
going and like you said you can identify
it's it seems like it's a little bit of
an income problem and maybe it's a
little bit of a I just needed a plan
problem hold on it sounds like it's a
massive massive income problem yeah it
is it is you're right bro you make
50,000 bucks total 40 48
probably yeah and that's including the
side the side hustles yes with four
kids yeah bro you're you're you're
videography dream is
over I I I'm I'm not playing you got to
go make some money you can be an
assistant manager at McDonald's and make
that money that's
real like you got to let that dream go
dude you got four kids and you're
drowning in in debt how much do you
owe uh total Dead about 140,000 holy
smokes dude okay okay okay yeah we're
the dream's over man or at least it's on
pause you can't afford that life you
can't afford it so you said you're over
qualified what makes you overqualified
what degree do you have what what are
they seeing on paper so I have a
bachelor's degree in uh mass
communications um I used to work in news
uhhuh um and news doesn't pay very well
right swi over neither is whatever
you're doing
now it pays a lot more than news all
right this is a wakeup call yeah this is
a wakeup call Cuz here's the problem we
can tell you all day I'm getting mad we
can tell you all day long here's a
solution here's a solution if you don't
want to see the solution there is no
solution you see what you want to see
you go through life and you can look for
reasons that you can or you look for
reasons that you can't right now dude
you are looking for every single reason
that you can't and you will find it
every single time but I promise you the
moment that you wake up and you say I
want to see reasons that I can do this
you will start to see them this is all
going on upstairs you have told yourself
that you've lost and youve told yourself
that you are the victim and there's no
getting out of this and only you can
control that John and I can tell you
till you're bleue in the face there's
options here you can look at this you
can look at that but we can't we can't
be the ones to change your mind and we
can't be the one to tell you we can only
tell you you can do it we can't go out
and do it for you we can't do it for you
so you've told yourself I won't do it I
won't do it that's what you told
yourself and I'm telling you you can say
you won't but don't tell me you can't
people pull themselves out of holes
every single day holes deeper than yours
they go out and they work and they get
it done because they know they can do it
and they know they need to do it this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
you're listening to the ramsy show
thanks for hanging out with us today I
your host Jade warshaw I am joined by my
other host for the day Dr John deloney
we're taking your calls so give us a
call it's the day before thank
Thanksgiving which is awesome and
Thanksgiving day is awesome but what's
really awesome is Black Friday and if
you are looking for some great deals be
sure to head over to ramsy solutions.com
store we've got some really great Black
Friday deals going on lots and lots of
books on sale on there uh Dave's got
some books on sale uh Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires John I
know you've got a couple on sale for
very low your new book is out go get it
my new book is out it's very low it's 10
bucks uh let's see George camel's got a
book out his is 20 bucks it's called
Breaking Free from broke my book is
called money's not a math problem but
I'll be honest out of all the book
releases that we have going on uh Rachel
Cruz has one out that I am like look if
you have kids this is for you the book
is called I'm glad for what I have and
it's teaching our kids about contentment
and I look John the way my kids are we
go to Target they're already telling me
on the way in to the store like what
they hope to get and I'm like you don't
need anything I've seen your room like
you don't need anything and so this book
is so great it's so heartwarming it's
got this message that really teach
teaches kids about like the the feeling
like like in entitlement contentment
true happiness does not come from stuff
like at the end of the day your
contentment your source of like okay
everything's good and fine it really
comes from Jesus Christ so if you were
wondering it is a faith-based ending but
that's all right by me you know and
honestly what a great message I don't
care really what your belief is it's
good to know that our contentment
doesn't come from stuff so if you're
interested in that you can head over to
ramsy solutions.com sstore and order
your copy it's 15 bucks I'm in it I love
it do it all right let's go straight to
the phone lines we've got Tony who's in
Syracuse New York what's going on
Tony sorry I threw you off thank you so
much for taking my call you're welcome
man what's
up so essentially I'm 21 I have a pretty
good job and I am recovering from a
gambling addiction I just quit a little
over a month ago and you got you have a
you have a 30-day
chip uh I do not I I'm not in any sort
of classes for it I've really been kind
of coaching myself through it how's that
going it's going good it's getting to a
point where I really don't have any urge
to do it okay I would say I caused
enough problems from it to where I kind
of got fed up and I'm pretty much just
trying to get myself back on track here
to better my finances currently and
going into the future and was just
looking for some advice on that okay um
Jade's gonna walk you through some stuff
and we're gonna honor you you got 30
days so sobriety a little bit over um 30
days so we're going to hook you up with
some free stuff to get you get you get
you started um to I mean to keep you
going um but I'm tell you right now
there is zero none no long-term life
change done in isolation
period so when it comes to your money
when it comes to not gambling when it
comes to um I don't know going to the
gym when it comes to your spiritual
whatever you got going on you have to
have at least somebody preferably more
than just one person that you can walk
alongside with you that you can call and
say dude I got the urge bad right now
can you come over or hey I'm coming over
or um dude I'm about to spin something I
just had somebody call from the past
wants me to come over like you've got to
have other people that you can
communicate with you can White Knuckle
for a while for
real and but man life will come hit you
in the mouth and you got to have other
people is that fair and I'm only telling
you that because I've just been doing
this too
long I agree okay you have somebody you
can call when things get
dicey no
I I would say I more so I rely on people
who I know care about me there's
definitely people close to me who I can
talk to about it I haven't really gone a
professional route that's fine that's
okay that's all right but you got people
in your life that know the extent of the
damage you've
done yes what did you do you said you
blew something up so bad you just you
quit what'd you
do well it was it kind of started with
me just just blowing paychecks sports
betting about a year ago uh just coming
into having some good money I kind of
didn't know what to do with it all at
first I was real good and then I found
out about sports betting had a problem
with that and what it really came down
to that was kind of my rock bottom was I
had been investing in crypto for a while
and I had about
10,000 and um so this was like money I
would not touch at for so many
circumstances I refused to touch it even
throughout me doing the sports betting
and I started to gamble that on crypto
casinos online and this was money that
to me you know regardless of how
volatile the crypto space is I was I
cherished it I was very reluctant to
touch it at all for a long time and
essentially I let that consume me and
blew every last dollar of that and that
was ultimately the thing that really hit
me hard enough to say okay this is this
is really bad I need to stop for good
you know all right so I'm tur this over
to Jay and she's gonna walk you through
the budgeting and all that stuff
but well can I ask a question yeah go
ahead um and I correct me go for I I
feel like usually when people dig into
these things it's cuz they're trying to
mask something else or like Escape in
some way can have you gotten to the
bottom of what that is because I can
give you all the money advice in the
world but if you don't know what that
thing was it's not going to help you I
don't
think am I is that fair enough John yeah
the the question is most people go to
these things to feel alive what is it
about your day-to-day life that you
don't feel like you got enough uh
adrenaline pumping through your
veins are you gone I think I may have
lost him oh oh did he bail on us that's
okay let's keep talking about it cuz he
can hear us yeah
um do you see what I'm my say my point
is if there's some sort of hurt or pain
or something about your life that sucks
and you're like I gotta I'm doing this
instead figuring out what that is I feel
like is a big piece of this that being
said that's his homework right right so
the the question really switched for me
it was about 10 years ago a little bit
more than that when I stopped asking
dude what's the matter with you why
would you gamble your paycheck away and
I start asking man what is happening in
your life that this is the best way your
body's figured out how to get through a
day exactly and until you figure that
out and that's why my first question is
you got a chip have you been sitting
around a table with with the room full
of people getting to the bottom of what
is your body trying to do numb or
distract or but he said no pump gasoline
through ve so he's just white knuckling
he's going for it some people the data
says they can they can do that for a
season but you got to have people that
you can call and they know exactly
what's going on they they know hey dude
um they I've shared my Amazon account
not me personally but I have given
somebody else access to my checking
account because I trust them and they're
going to look at look at it every once
in a while people who are trying to get
off pornography they they give their
computer login to somebody else right or
whatever right um real accountability
it's having accountability and not in a
judgmental way but in a hey I'm here
with you kind of way right and it let
your body
go and then you can get to the real
stuff and I'd say he needs that when it
comes to this money1 years old he needs
somebody who like you said has access
can log in and see what you've been
spending your money on so that it's not
just you giving your word oh no dude ien
I haven't do I didn't do it I didn't do
it like they need to be with you and
walking with you we say all the time you
need accountability but this is a whole
other level of that and I think that
it's extremely necessary um you know at
the end of the day if you've acquired
debt from gambling we got to start
working to pay it off but first things
first I think with him just getting in
the habit of saying this is my paycheck
and I I do what I said I'm gonna budget
with my paycheck like don't get caught
up with a bunch of other things just
practice the habit of I stick to my
budget whatever that is I make 3,000
bucks a month I I I plan the $3,000 a
month and I stick to it if you can get
there I think that's good and then we go
to the next level okay how do I bump it
up a notch and now I'm going to start
accomplishing different goals so he
hasn't done this in a while obviously
he's been battling with this but that's
the next step for you get on an every
dollar budget take whatever money you're
getting in budget it and stick to the
budget build up some confidence that you
can do what you say you're going to do
and in the meantime make sure you have
somebody else looking at those numbers
with you it feels different when you
know someone's looking over your
shoulder this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw joined by Dr John deloney
and it is officially Thanksgiving over
here cuz John is gobling up these
cookies I got cookies man so good they
make them over here at the cafe they're
they're the best I'm not mad at you look
when I get home I'm going to get into it
I don't know what I'm getting into but
I'm going to get involved in something I
know that the scripture and quote of the
day it says give thanks to the Lord for
he is good his love endures forever amen
that's 1st Chronicles 6 1634 or as some
people might say one
Chronicles did you get my joke that was
excellent that was that was incredible
well done oh boy and then Ernest timway
said my favorite
book Ernest timing way said now is no
time to think of what uh of what you do
not have think of what you can do with
what there is I love that in the spirit
of thankfulness and gratitude I love
that so much let's go straight to the
phone lines where we've got Ian in
Chicago
Illinois what's going on Ian hey guys
how are you doing
well um yeah so my wife and I have been
doing baby step two I've been on it
since July of
2022 it's going really well kicking butt
um I had $130,000 of IRS debt W and I've
knocked it down to below just below 60
Grand now okay and I'm wondering should
I get a loan to get it out of their
hands and stop paying the extra
sees why do you have this IRS
debt so I'm also a recovering addict and
for several years I did not pay my taxes
I I work as a um I'm responsible for
paying quarterly estimated taxes is
self-employed and I just didn't do it
for five years because I was messed
up okay
um how quickly are you going to be able
to pay off this final 60k like what's
your margin like what are you throwing
at it each
month it's been so my the minimum I'm
throwing at it every month is
$2,700 but lately I've really been able
to go hard and throw extra at it so like
we've paid off $26,000 of it in the last
two months which feels awesome that is
amazing I'm so proud of you man way to
go I'm so proud of you it's incredible
I'm so grateful we saw you guys at
Willow Creek when you guys were here in
Chicago it was awesome we just so
inspired man I'm inspired the fact what
you're telling me you're kicking this
debts butt yeah now what else do you
have after it because I have a feeling
that that's kind of more what's making
you consider this route do you have
other debt besides this IRS debt so we
just got married in September and we
married our debt so my my wife brought
in $53,000 a student loan debt and then
that's it we've paid off our cars we
paid off our credit cards yeah you know
I probably wouldn't do that I understand
the sentiment behind your thought of I
can move it over here and there's less
fees and penalties but you're going to
have an interest rate and my guess is
that you're you know it's kind of
trading one set of problems for another
set of problems um had this debt still
been at the 130 possibly we could have
talked about it if you were telling me
hey I'm getting hit with these kind of
taxes and these kinds of penalties like
I'd want to know exact numbers but
honestly at this point in the journey
man I would just run it down the field
what what do you have a settlement with
them
I did and then during Co I was out of
work and I I so I had like an
installment agreement but insur or
interest and penalties still acre even
during that yeah what are the penalty
like if you're I'm I'm tempted to say go
get one what I want to know what the
interest and the penalties are like what
are what are we talking about per month
when does it hit is it per quarter how
how's it going the IRS interest is it
amounts to about 8 and a half% okay and
the loan I was looking at 9% so pretty
similar okay um and then the penalties I
don't know like they they get they seem
Maybe random or quarterly I haven't
figured out probably quarterly really
hard to talk to someone there yeah it
yes sure you are right about that my
friend man if it's a was I I just don't
want to do business but who's going to
give you a $60,000 loan at 9%
exactly uh
soy I ain't going and I am telling you
no I am not going yeah you're making
just you're trading one deal with the
Devil with for another one at that and
the thing is you're burning through this
like you just told us you paid off
almost $30,000 in a few short months so
I think you got momentum and you're
right the IRS is the worst like they
it's like they only want to talk to you
in letter form one letter once a year
it's the worst so um I think you keep
running the ball down the field and I
think by the end of the year you're
going to be you're going to look up not
by the end of this year but but for sure
like going into the next year in 12
months you're going to look up and this
is going to be gone and um I I would not
get in bed with anybody else on this I
just go through it the only person I I
would consider getting in bed with Jade
would be if and I say a local credit
union wouldn't give you $6,000 exactly
okay if you got it down to 25 or and you
sat down with the banker and said here's
my trajectory and I would actually be
honest I am a recovering addict here's
where I've been here's the Last 5 Years
here's what I've paid off I'm sick of
doing doing with the government they may
do that ESP if you can look at a banker
in the eye and shake their hand they may
do that yeah they might do it but 60,000
bucks dude it's I would not get in bed
with another loan shark like another
Nationwide loan shark that's as big as
the IRS cuz at the end of the day I mean
8% I mean that's that's a that's a
student loan like it's it's not crazy if
you had told me it was like 22% like
something crazy like a credit card
interest rate I would have definitely
been more along the lines of how can we
get this lower now those quarter
uh fees that you were talking about if
you could guess what have those been
what do they look like is it just $20 as
bad as in well yeah like over a few
years I think they climbed up to like
between 800 and two grand or something
total yeah yeah just pay it off pay it
off it's not worth it I think it's it
sucks to pay extra but that's kind of
part of the stupid tax here right is you
didn't pay it yeah I yeah whatever you
want to call it it's didn't pay it and
they they're paying you you have a
penalty on it you know and it's hard
sometimes you can't get out of that so
hey what was your why I got you man let
me let me turn the tables and ask you a
question what was your magic um what was
the it's not magic it's probably a ton
of hard work and humility what what's
the path you took out of out of
addiction 12 step baby there you go all
the time 60 months you're five years
out I'm three and a half years wow dude
I'm so proud of you congratulations you
got little ones such a blessing what's
that you got little ones not yet but
we're trying awesome man I love it
congratulations congratulations
congratulations you got six figures of
debt just like Jade and I did and we're
both free and you will be too man I'm
proud of you oh I love it that's a great
way to enter into Thanksgiving being
super thankful look IRS debt is nothing
to play with and for anybody listening
if you have IRS debt even though we
always say list your debts from smallest
to largest right and you pay the little
one first regardless of interest rate
IRS debt is one of the only debts that
we say no matter what put that at the
top of the list because you don't want
to mess with the IRS number one they are
so hard to communicate with and number
two they have the power to literally
reach into your account and garnish your
wages for stuff they have the ability to
take your passport away if you don't pay
like there are real things that they can
do to make your life very difficult so
if anybody has that sort of debt always
put it first that's what you want to do
um and that's what he's doing the fact
that he blew through man I mean he's
almost done I'm excited for him and he's
sober and they're having a kid look it
doesn't get any better than that John
good for you that's rich impressive very
very cool all right I would say we have
time to take another call but I don't
think we do Casey is from Kansas City oh
yeah we won't have time let's do this
James what's something you're uh
grateful for as we head into
Thanksgiving besides me and
Jade well that's funny that's what I was
going to say um I am are you more
grateful for I am thankful um for my
family ah yeah it's not what you were
saying during the break but we'll let
that ride on here that's cool that's
cold I'm not going to tell them what you
were saying during the break cuz I can't
say it on the air that's fair that's
that is also true Jade what are you
grateful for oh man you know I'm really
grateful I had some friends come see me
that you guys know I'm from South
Florida and so I miss my friends and my
friends surprised me they came up here
and uh yesterday two days ago when I was
working out doing my workout in the
garage at like 6:00 a.m. in the morning
my best buddy popped in there and I
almost lost it John it was the best so
really grateful for friends friends are
medicine man that's incredible I had a
buddy um gosh he's in his 50s he's a CEO
of a lawn care company in Texas his
name's Kevin and he called me yesterday
and said hey before Thanksgiving you're
going to hear these words from me and
you're going to sit there and take it I
love you and I'm glad that you're my
friend and I was just I was just uh
really blessed that he did that I'm
grateful for my friends I love it find
something that you're thankful for
there's a lot going on things want to
steal your joy they want to take your
peace don't let it happen you get to
control that you get to control your joy
and your peace and you've got a lot to
be grateful for you've got a lot to be
thankful for hey I'm thankful for you
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
a